jusqu'à maintenant wallace bones était
coupé du monde
la route de la côte des nouvelles galles
du sud vient tout juste de rouvrir les
pompiers éteignent encore les derniers
brasier les arbres dangereux ont été
coupées ou à l'as commence à récupérer
ce qu'il peut des ateliers et du
matériel de sa petite entreprise
d'excavation
tout a brûlé mais il a sauvé sa maison
le tout a duré moins de 45 minutes il
s'est retrouvé sous une pluie de braises
le vent était très violent il a vu
arriver le feu de deux côtés il était
dans les 11 heures le jour du nouvel an
belle voix lasse essaie de contrôler les
braises avec ce boyau
il a en partie fondu il reçoit vite
l'aide de deux jeunes pompiers
mais il ne peut vraiment compter que sur
lui-même un moment donné ça pompe tombe
en panne
il se rend vers le réservoir monte dans
sa pelle mécanique des places le troncs
de palmiers brûlé qui fait obstacle
et il répare sa pompe il a fait tout ce
qu'il a pu mais il commence à se sentir
mal et à prendre des décisions insensées
ils se reposent quelques instants dans
son auto et se rafraîchit avec la
climatisation pas un instant il a pensé
qu'il pouvait mourir
no time to paneque paniqué aurait été
elle n'a il se rend compte qu'il doit
évacuer ses deux fils et leurs familles
sont venues aider wallace à récupérer ce
qui peut l'être les pères sont immenses
les assurances ne couvriront pas le
tiers des dommages témoin je serais
parti l'une de ses belles filles
s'appelle gabriel la chance elle a
quitté saint lambert il ya sept ans elle
croit que wallace a pris de gros risques
à refaire il ne resterait pas à la
propriété pour essayer de sauver une
maison la maison sera sauvée grâce à
l'aide de plusieurs personnes qui ont
fini de maîtriser l'incendié
où allait se comptent très chanceux mais
il a perdu son voisin et ami l'aurait
mort d'une crise cardiaque ou d'
asphyxie
il vivait dans cette maison il est l'une
des 24 victimes des feux de forêts qui
ravagent l'australie a conduit une
maison à terre une maison encore là une
maison à terre gabriel nous montre les
nombreuses maisons détruites dans les
environs elles sont toutes en dehors des
agglomérations
si tu restais pour sauver la propriété
tu avais des chances à la sauver mais la
majorité de mon à qui j'ai parlé qui
disait je restais ne leur ferai plus
cette région reste encore sur ses gardes
les incendies peuvent reprendre à tout
moment jean michel leprince sera du
canada ahola d'où la nouvelle galles du
sud